hi everybody one thing I often hear is
women don't really understand how to
achieve that natural look with their
makeup so I'm here with my friend Alison
and we're going to do a tutorial on how
to achieve that look on your own with
your own makeup the first step is to
start with a pore filler now we're going
to apply a layer that's all over the
face because pores this size of her age
just really aren't natural the next step
is all over coverage now I chose a BB
cream as opposed to a traditional
foundation because it is lighter and
it's going to give a much more natural
smooth finish you'll cover all of that
redness and all those introspections
next we're going to go in with a
concealer it's going to give you that
really nice naturally airbrushed
Photoshop look if you have some dark
circles under the eye very common get
this mole here yeah I really like that
mole I think you take any character now
we're going to seal that all in with a
powder I chose a mineral powder because
it's made with all natural ingredients
and minerals where it is event the next
step is to contour the face this is just
going to really enhance the natural bone
structure in your face so go ahead and
like a fish yeah like a fish you can see
it's enhancing her natural cheekbone
basically we're just going to reshape
your face alright so now you got to add
the blush right on the apples of the
cheek this is my favorite part the eyes
since we are going for our natural look
I chose the nudes palette you can't
really get much more natural than them
there's so many steps well you know what
a parlor
droll Herbies born this way now that
we've applied the eyeshadow we're going
to go in apply a couple more coats of
concealer blush you know you're gonna do
it all again
well yeah you want good coverage the
final step for the eyes is the mascara
we're just gonna make those eyelashes
look bigger fuller blacker all right so
we're gonna put on about three or four
coats of this what was that that was one
coat it was one coat the final step is
the lip it's a really natural nudish
color so it looks like her skin tone
only a better version oh my god it's so
much better and good and just like that
that's all it takes to get that natural
murk I'm probably going to break out
from all the makeup on my face but I
guess the good news is is I can just use
more makeup to cover that up